Why is the government trying to ban
TikTok, the popular social media
app which is owned by ByteDance, a
Chinese company, has come under fire
from both Republicans and Democrats
who are determined to get rid of it.
They're worried the Chinese
government has too much influence on
the platform. Never mind that more
than 150 million Americans use
Tik Tok to express themselves
creatively, consume news they
wouldn't find elsewhere, and also to
keep themselves entertained.
Nanny state politicians like Senator
Josh Hawley, President Joe Biden
think they should have the power to
control what kinds of foreign
content you are allowed to see.
Not everyone in Washington thinks
banning Tik Tok is a good idea.
Senator Rand Paul recently denounced
the idea of giving the Biden
administration more power to control
social media.
I think we should beware of those
who peddle fear.
who use fear to coax Americans
to relinquish our liberties,
to regulate and limit our First
Amendment rights.
Paul is right.
Here are three reasons why letting
the federal government prohibit
TikTok is an idiotic idea.
First off, the dangers of Tik Tok
have been overstated.
Yes, it's true you can find really
vile content on the platform.
It's not all dance videos, recipes
and makeup tutorials.
But that's not unique to Tik Tok.
There's bad stuff in all corners
of the internet. Just because a
website or an app is bad sometimes
for some people doesn't mean we
should violate the First Amendment
rights of millions of others.
Censorship is censorship.
Even if it's well-intended, we
should leave the policing to
individuals, families and
schools to set restrictions on
social media usage.
Not the federal government.
Now, it's true that Tik Tok is
unique in that the Chinese Communist
Party can pressure the company in
ways that are bad.
It's very likely that Tik Tok mutes
certain controversial subjects
and takes down the accounts of
dissidents in order to protect the
CCP.
But the sad truth is the US
government has applied similar
pressure to American social media
companies like Facebook and Twitter.
Journalists have discovered that
federal agencies, including the FBI,
the Department of Homeland Security,
regularly asked Twitter to delete
content the government didn't
approve of. My own reporting, for
Reason, has revealed that the White
House and the CDC applied constant
pressure on Facebook
during the pandemic to restrict
speech. If members of Congress are
really so worried about government
propagandists controlling the
discourse on social media,
well, they should start by putting
their own house in order.
Lastly, any new law that
gives the feds the power to ban
TikTok could easily be
weaponized against other companies.
The RESTRICT Act, which is
co-sponsored by Republican Senator
John Thune and Democratic Senator
Mark Warner, empowers the Commerce
Department to take action against
foreign threats on social media.
But lawmakers, national intelligence
experts and mainstream media pundits
are constantly accusing Facebook
of allowing too much foreign
misinformation on the platform.
This is the Patriot Act 2.0.
If we give the government more tools
to police Tik Tok, they're going to
use them against all of us.
So let's leave TikTok alone.
Not just because of the dance
videos, but also because of
the First Amendment.